perfect preservation ladies and gentlemen perfect
preservation that's what our muslim friends have
been telling us for decades perfect preservation
right down to the letter from the time it was
revealed to muhammad seeking evidence for this
claim we opened their most trusted sources and
we read about entire chapters of the quran being
lost forever large passages being lost forever
versus being eaten by a sheep lost forever how
did our muslim friends respond when we showed
them that their own sources repeatedly declare
that the quran was changed over and over and over
they said perfect preservation right down
to the letter hatuntas and j smith went to
speaker's corner with 26 different arabic qurans
not 26 different translations 26 different
arabic qurans how did our muslim friends respond
perfect preservation right down to the letter
non-muslims are publishing entire
books filled with quran variants how
do our muslim friends respond perfect
preservation right down to the letter
fortunately after decades of non-muslims
showing muslims what's in their own sources
and their own manuscripts after decades of muslim
apologists lying about the history of the quran
there are finally some muslim scholars who are
starting to admit that there are holes in the
narrative and it's very clear to you and to every
single very advanced student and specialist that
the standard narrative has holes in it that's what
i'm gonna say why are they finally acknowledging
that there's a problem because the evidence
is piling up too fast and muslim scholars are
realizing that the longer they deny reality the
more shame and embarrassment they'll face later
now the new problem we face is that even as
muslim scholars are finally acknowledging that
there are holes in the narrative muslims are
reinterpreting the words of their own scholars
insisting that what their scholars really mean is
that there are simply different ways to pronounce
certain words in the quran this is sheer nonsense
sheik yaserkati would not be in full panic mode
over some pronunciation differences muhammad
hijab wouldn't have needed to delete an entire
section of an interview if all sheikh yasrikadi
had meant was that there are different possible
pronunciations of the same word but let's focus on
dr shabir ali who has recently admitted that there
are different qurans in different parts of the
world today most muslims read the quran in a text
that is referred to as the egyptian edition of
1924. that's how scholars refer to it most muslims
may not have realized that this is the designation
uh for that uh manuscript for for that text to to
muslims in general this is just simply the quran
but this is not the only text of the quran that
is read throughout the world he's also admitted
that there are differences in quran manuscripts
so there was this period in which muslims
had the opportunity to teach others the quran
without insisting on the precise words recently
a manuscript has been discovered from sanaa in
in yemen and it's referred to as a sana manuscript
that manuscript has two layers of quranic writing
the lower layer has been scraped off and the upper
layer has the quranic text written over now the
upper layer text quite closely corresponds to what
muslims are reading in in the world today as the
text of the quran the lower text that has been
scraped off has some variation from what muslims
are reading in today's text what's disturbing is
that even when someone like dr shabir ali admits
that there are different arabic qurans and even
when he admits that there are differences in the
manuscripts the muslims in the comments section
are still claiming that all shabir really means
is that there are different pronunciations
of the same arabic words that's all he means
no that's not what he means my muslim friends
feel free to contact him and ask him send a
message to dr shabir ali and ask shabir when you
say that there are differences in the manuscripts
do you only mean that there are different
pronunciations of the same arabic words
shabir is going to give you an education
because shabir knows what non-muslim scholars
are finding when they go through manuscripts
of the quran they're finding missing words
added words changed words words moved around
words written over words erased it's a giant mess
as an example yesterday dr dan brubacher
a textual critic of quran manuscripts
posted a video where he shows a single page of a
quran manuscript he shows that there are no less
than 11 textual variants and corrections on
that one page and these aren't simply different
pronunciations of the same arabic word let me give
you one example of what he means from the video
this is verse 6 110. this part of the verse reads
we let them wander blindly on in their insolence
and i've circled there the words that roughly
corresponds to the word that we're looking at for
you to yanahim because in this manuscript the word
to hyanihim does not exist rather it its place is
taken by the word hazihim so it is an alternate
word if he has him actually is used as you can see
in another verse not too far from here in the same
surah then leave them plunged in their foolish
talk so here at 6 110 with this alternate word it
has the reading of we let them uh remain plunged
in their blindness or remain immersed perhaps in
their blindness makes sense to my understanding
of the arabic it does make sense it's just an
alternate alternate reading a different word
from what we have today different arabic words
different meanings different translations and what
are our muslim friends going to conclude from this
perfect preservation right down to the letter
my muslim friends do you have any clue what
kind of damage you're doing to the future of your
religion right now once this lie has been exposed
possibly the biggest lie in history the supposed
perfect preservation of a book that was repeatedly
changed and corrupted once this lie has been
exposed we are never going to believe anything
you tell us about your religion ever again when
you lie to our faces about what we can see with
our own eyes you destroy your own credibility
when your own sources say that entire chapters
of the quran were lost and that large passages
were lost and that countless verses were lost
and you say perfect preservation right down to
the letter it becomes impossible to believe you
when you say that there are no textual variants
in the entire history of the quran while textual
critics who go through the manuscripts say
that they've found tens of thousands of
textual variants there's simply no way to take
you seriously ever again this is so fun to watch
i encourage everyone to click on dr brubaker's new
video so that he can take you through 11 variants
and corrections on a single page of a manuscript
of a book that's been supernaturally protected by
the great god allah i think we can all agree that
if a book has all the features of a book that's
been changed and corrupted even though it's been
perfectly preserved it must indeed be a miracle